we had a coach party one night that
stormed the doors of the bar we was in
and there was only two of us working and
uh we ended up out in the street
fighting with him in an open area which
is never good one particular guy I think
I hit him three times knocked him on his
ass three times but he just kept getting
up and you're in the middle of like
everyone's trying to get to you to you
know hit you to punch you to kick you
and I went to do a roundhouse kick on
this fella and uh he caught my foot so
I'm standing there on one foot and on my
leg in the air and he's holding on he's
as shocked as I was he's caught his foot
he's like right but I couldn't reach him
without me with me fist because it's not
as long as my neck and uh so I just
rammed my hand straight into his eyes as
hard as I could and his eye just came
straight out on his cheek
um and needless to say he went down very
hard and he didn't get up after that one